sí
hasta ahora hemos limitado nuestra
simulación a solamente tener movimiento
vertical pero queremos que nuestro
cabello se mueva en varias direcciones
así que tenemos que actualizar nuestro
código para incluir dos dimensiones de
movimiento es bastante fácil hacer esto
solo tenemos que duplicar muchas de
nuestras variables de modo que tengamos
tanto la componente x como la jep por
ahora solo tenemos la posición inicial
vertical llamada posición white así que
voy a agregar una nueva llamada posición
x también voy a agregar una nueva
variable para almacenar la componente
horizontal de la velocidad a esta la voy
a llamar velocity ex y debe ser
inicializa da igual a cero igual que
velocity white porque nuestra partícula
comienza desde el reposo ahora voy a ir
a la función draw y duplicar la ecuación
de modo que también tengamos una
componente horizontal
por el momento hay una fuerza de resorte
spring force white pero no hay spring
force ex voy a agregar la ahora springs
force ex es igual a menos cada
multiplicada por posición x menos 5 ex
voy a agregar una nueva variable que se
llama jumping force ex y la voy a hacer
igual laden ping multiplicada por
velocity ex
con estas nuevas variables puedo agregar
un nuevo cálculo de fuerza neta en la
dirección x llamada force ex esta va a
ser un poco diferente a force why porque
podemos ignorar la gravedad ya que la
fuerza de gravedad sólo actúa en la
dirección vertical así que force x es
igual a screen force ex - de ping force
ex ahora pasemos a la aceleración voy a
agregar una nueva variable llamada a
celebration ex y va a ser igual a force
ex dividida entre la masa hagamos lo
mismo con la velocidad resultante voy a
agregar una nueva variable llamada
velocity ex que es igual a velocity ex
más a celebration ex multiplicada por
time step por último podemos actualizar
la posición de modo que también tenga
una componente horizontal esto lo voy a
hacer con una variable llamada position
x la cual es igual la posición x más
velocity ex multiplicada por time step
ahora ya tenemos las componentes xy
separa la fuerza la aceleración la
velocidad y la posición ahora sólo
tenemos que actualizar nuestro código d
de modo que el círculo que representa a
nuestra particular y la línea que
representa a nuestro resorte se puedan
mover en la dirección x simplemente voy
a agregar posición x al final de la
línea que está conectada a la masa y
para el círculo que representa nuestra
masa le voy a agregar posición ex a su
posición central ahora ve qué pasa
cuando ejecuto el código si movimiento
en dos dimensiones para hacer nuestras
películas hacemos lo mismo pero en tres
dimensiones
usando una tercera componente z ese es
un buen proyecto adicional en el cual
puedes empezar a pensar pero vamos a
pausar aquí para que puedas estar cómodo
con este código antes de avanzar al
último paso